So we are lucky enough to be here this morning to interview Charlie White and it's May
18th, 2000 and 11th.
It's to thank you so much for agreeing to do this.
I want to start off with just asking you to tell us your earliest recollections, where
you're born, what year, and where you grew up.
I was born and Detroit Michigan, and in the court, I was the youngest of nine children.
Four brothers and four sisters, and all over the court.
There are two of us left, and myself and the brother next to me.
There was a typical child, we were poor, but I said that's not really know.
I never stopped.
I always said food.
I always had a roof over my head, and when I closed, and the old sand was cardboard,
and the shoe we had a few of those shoes.
But I was just a typical child of those days.
What kind of things do you remember doing as a child playing games?
Yes, of course.
My brother, next to me, I've walked kind of follow-up and it's what's there.
He played basketball, and he played in high school.
He didn't go to college, but he played high school.
Well, I used to watch his games, and we've hit the playgrounds on the weekend.
We've sat every morning at the break of dawn.
We were out in the alleys and on the playgrounds playing basketball.
There was more like a religion.
We played all kinds of sports, and contrary to property to relief.
There was a pretty good hockey player's in my neighborhood.
We played hockey, and we played tennis and all that, but basketball just became the sport.
basketball and football.
It's a good baseball player's trip.
The basketball became the game of choice, and I played YMCA.
Okay.
The Jewish Community Center.
But also one thing I did when I was 10 years old.
It's 19 years old.
I used to swim for the YMCA.
And I wasn't too bad, but we transferred it closer to a place near my home.
And everybody left the YMCA.
The coach left and everybody followed him.
We used to swim against the cross-town teams, from the country clubs, and all that.
We just pretty good against the YMCA.
So swimming was big to me for about three, four years from about nine until about 13.
I was still playing basketball, but I did.
I just swimming in the evening at people.
Sure.
But that's basically what you call growing up.
That's right around the racialization of Detroit was there.
You said you swim against the kids in the country club today.
So having kind of feeling towards you guys.
Well, they did, but nothing was said.
They just felt, you know, they had that superior feeling that they were better.
Because they had the best, much better facilities.
And we were at decent facilities, but they had to country clubs and the whole thing.
And, but you know, that feeling was there.
And it was always there that we wanted to win.
It was a, Detroit was a, I love Detroit, but it was, it was polarized.
Yeah.
I mean, most of the Blacks lived in about three or four different areas.
And the Italians lived here.
And Jewish people lived there.
And the Polish people lived on the PlayScore of HMG.
Sure.
And great athletes came out at HMG.
And that was like, didn't be high schools in HMG.
So we played against each other in, in, throughout the city.
But it was mostly, there was only one,
that I could remember, one school at that time,
that had mixed athletic teams.
Okay.
And that was cast tech, which was one of the top schools in the city.
Roughly, by year, you were talking about,
in the mid 50s.
So your high school, as I'm hearing you say,
it was not being segregated.
No, it was just.
Well, I went to cast tech.
Yes, I did.
To begin with, but I didn't stay there ended up back in my neighborhood school.
But, yeah, the neighborhood school that I played the most basketball in was,
it was not segregated.
The cast tech was.
And they have always said pretty good teams.
Okay.
But, you know, it was pretty much it.
I did a lot of odd jobs growing up as a kid to generate income.
I learned this from all my brothers and sisters.
They all worked in school and did all of things.
They all graduated from high school.
None of what the college I was the only one.
Okay.
But, I worked for, you know, cutting lawns, washing windows, you know, whatever.
Sure.
And then I got a job with large grocery chain, progress.
Okay.
And I started working in a meat department,
just kind of cleaning up and everything.
And then I ended up getting a permanent job as a stock boy.
And, you know, you thought, okay.
And the job was rough in the neighborhood.
I mean, you had to kind of establish yourself.
But, sure.
I decided in 1958 that I had seen enough,
and the friend of mine and I decided to,
say, let's go see the world and join the military.
Okay.
Yeah.
And we could have gone in for two years and gone to the Far East.
Okay.
But I said, now let's go in for three and go to Europe.
We're going to be seeing a few more places.
And that's what happened.
Okay.
And you were about 18.
18.
20.
Almost 20.
19.
Thank you.
So I started, and I played a lot of basketball, and I was there.
In the military.
Yeah.
Can you talk about that?
Of course.
Well, we came in.
I went in and into four knots.
Okay.
A little bit right aside a little bit.
And they had a,
Yeah.
Can't team.
Okay.
And I went out for it.
But I didn't want to have been ordered to make that team.
You had to kind of stay in the states and you travel around.
And I said, don't want to stay here.
So I want to go to Europe.
And I kind of got on the team there and we played.
We could be at like 50 games, schedules.
And then we heard in the Soviet.
At the series.
Yeah.
And then I played a lot of games.
I enjoyed myself.
You know, we went to, went all over.
We're in, all over Germany.
Right.
And that time.
The military was disagreed.
Yeah.
So you were actually.
With white teammates.
Yeah.
So you were there with several racial issues in the military.
Can you talk about those?
Yeah.
The majority of MPs were military police were white and from the south.
Okay.
And they harassed us.
Consistently.
Whenever we would be out.
There was one.
There was one African guy there named Bobby.
Something other.
And he had a club.
Very nice, popular club.
And we would go down there.
And you know what?
Twice a month.
And these were coming.
Just kind of read the club.
You know, pull everybody out.
It's good.
And coffee.
You know.
We, our team used to go down there.
Well, this was a track team at this time.
Okay.
And we had white kids on the track team.
And they would tell them to go home.
Which they wouldn't go.
They would stay with us and they would take us.
You know, to jail the lockup.
But we'd get out the next couple hours because we called our.
Colonel and blah, blah, blah.
You know, it was just a rest.
Sure.
And it's just, it's just continued.
Yeah.
Sure.
We continue.
What else?
Some of your experiences in Germany has.
So I'm.
What position did you have in the military then?
Because it wasn't just fully accurate.
Right.
You had a regular job.
Yeah.
I was just a.
That was an armoured infantry.
What they called it.
But I didn't spend a lot of stuff.
Oh, no.
I spent what they called TDWI.
It was a temporary duty.
And I would play sports.
Oh, because I also was on the track team.
Oh, I didn't even know they had to.
Yeah.
Okay.
Not high jumped.
And triple jumped and brought jumped.
It was a nice long jump.
Mm-hmm.
Whatever.
But yeah, I did that too.
So I did that too.
Pretty much keep from.
Yeah.
You don't do it anymore.
Every duty is guaranteed.
Right, right.
Kids in patrol.
Yeah.
I was such a thing.
Right.
Yeah.
So did someone recognize you in the military as being a potential athlete
for eventually college or how did that team talk to me now about how?
It was really funny.
We were in a gym one day and I was shooting around.
And this kid from Southern California.
He's on our team.
Jones.
Dick Jones.
He came in the gym and he asked me, see, what are you going to do?
You're getting close to my time to come back.
Three states.
And he said, what are you going to do when you got a military officer?
You know, I really hadn't thought much about it.
And he said, you got to go out to California and go to junior college and say,
junior college is free and then maybe you can get a scholarship to a four year school.
And I thought he was joking.
So I threw the ball out and told him to get out and chase them out of the gym.
Well, guess what happened.
I did just that.
I got a certificate of four in your firm Germany.
Got out of the army went to junior college.
Then came with Durgen State.
Okay.
Now, the thing that I noticed when I got here, I started seeing names in the paper from some
of the other junior colleges in Southern California, but as I knew from Detroit.
So there was a lot of young kids kept from Detroit who came out to California and went to
junior college.
What was that lot of you think?
Because we heard some very similar thing from North because he said that a lot of
guys from his neighborhood is in Washington, ended up in California.
What was maybe going on back?
Well, for one thing, the junior colleges back there were not free.
We're free in East Coast.
They were free out here.
Okay.
And if you were 21, you could establish residency and you did not have to pay out of state fees.
So you could go to junior college free.
And these coaches would help you get a little odd job here and there where you could work.
And then you didn't have to scholarship to a four year school.
So a lot of kids and plus, you know, who wouldn't want to come to California?
Detroit, you know, I mean, it's snowed this high freezing.
And there's a lot of different things going on.
Guys were getting in trouble.
Friends, relatives, you know, we're in that mix.
Yeah.
So that you see as you pay, I mean, when I was about 17,
I had to be 18 to go into the pool of halls, but everybody forward some kind of neighborhood.
And I used to hang around in the pool hall and, you know, see a lot of stuff going on.
Sure.
So you want to get away from that, mainly.
Yes, you know, just more future.
Yeah.
Just get out of that mix for a while.
And that was, you know, they just got started coming.
Once a couple of guys came.
Yeah.
A lot of guys started coming.
And I could say that I saw the guys names down in,
and I had different places that from Detroit.
And so I said, yeah, it was the best thing for me to do.
But anyway, that's what I did.
I came to Oregon, stayed in, you know.
Sure.
I'm going to come back down to that.
That's great.
So you're playing in a junior college.
And someone identifies you and says,
Yeah.
Who is that?
You know, a Paul and I were talking about that.
I don't recall who it was.
Okay.
But I think it was a sky that played with Paul.
His name was Doug.
And I don't remember his last name.
I was not a factor last time.
I think I heard he was in pretty poor health.
But he and Paul played together.
They were good friends.
Sure.
And I think he might've seen me play in some tournament.
He lived in the general area.
Okay.
And Paul and told him about me.
But one thing that had happened, the year before came,
where a slight skill came down to recruit me.
Okay.
They might've actually came to my house.
They always see size.
I'm not going to be married.
And I talk with him.
You know.
And that didn't feel good.
Just didn't feel feel warm and fuzzy, I guess.
Right.
And then a couple of other coaches told me some stories about him.
You know, that I probably would get to play with.
And you know, sitting on the bench.
And that sort of thing.
Right.
And I said, well, that's not a good sign.
So I just didn't come here.
Right.
And then the next year when Paul came down and we set on and talked.
Like I said, I just felt it.
Right.
You know, you feel something.
Yeah.
And like I said, when we talked about me graduating, I told him I need probably more than two years.
He said, well, I can't give you that in writing.
Yeah.
But I promise you.
I'll introduce you to you.
That you graduate.
You know, anything over the two right need to graduate.
Right.
And I felt that.
And then when I came up here, they focused on education right away as opposed to, you know,
just ask about and laid out what I needed to do.
And then that's when I started taking classes.
And you got through.
Yeah.
You come back to your situation with the class deal.
At that point, the team was completely not to say it.
The team was segregated in a sense.
There was no African Americans.
No.
Right.
But in Southern California, there were actually work teams that were very, well, sure.
Very few are mixed.
Sure.
I wonder how, in your opinion, how did he, you think that he sort of rationalized that he wasn't
going to allow his team necessarily to have an edge.
Because at that point, I think it was really recognized that having African American players
on your team was a really an edge because they brought a different game to the game that
Norm was actually talking to us about the game that he was forced to play.
And that is a very kind of contrient.
Sure.
Controlled control.
Yeah.
It was that completely different.
Running plays.
Yeah.
Picking screens.
We're in a playground that was, you know.
He's got it done.
Yeah.
We had a bag.
Good to late.
So whatever.
You know, we were out in looping there before it came in the college.
Sure.
We throw the ball up.
You know, I really don't know.
I try to figure this out because every year.
And that's had some good teams.
Yeah.
But every year, almost every year.
For two years, specifically, they're just focused hard.
I know.
Okay.
Be a Russell.
Yeah.
Was that the NSF?
And they always played in the regions on the West Coast.
And the West Coast teams used to beat him every time.
And all of them always had players.
They're called.
Right.
And I would have thought to myself.
Yeah.
You know.
You know, I don't know.
You know, and you know, the thing that they mentioned about the quota thing they had.
Yeah.
You start one at home.
Two on the road.
Yeah.
But be a Russell calling the phrase.
You say, but five when you're behind.
Yeah.
We're going to be a Russell started then.
No.
But I heard another explanation of that.
You start one at home.
Yeah.
And two on the road.
Because you got to have somebody to room together.
Oh, interesting.
Yeah.
Sure.
And also at that time.
In some parts of the country.
You can find logic.
Yeah.
To black players.
So, you know, if you had to go play in some areas.
Yeah.
You know, see how to like the old.
When Jackie Robinson was playing baseball.
The team stayed here.
And he found him a place to stay in the neighborhood.
That's someone's home.
Yeah.
You know, like that.
So I know some coaches had mentioned that.
And they were wary of where that in some sort of, you know, felt uncomfortable with that.
Right.
But I don't, I just don't know.
I, I, I, I, I, I, I think he might have wanted to pull a trigger, but I don't know.
He just did.
Yeah.
And plus that weren't a lot of kids up here for him to.
Recruited.
And most of his kids were, were localed on the he go back and look.
Yeah.
No.
I think at the time Washington probably had some.
Washington had it.
African American.
Yeah.
You know, you saw, that's California clearly had long.
You saw.
You see, I don't had a fever.
The rest of Oregon.
They played them all the time.
Yeah.
The sky was kind of holding the line.
And I was comparing them to rough.
When I was trying to understand what was going on.
What was this guy trying to do?
But that was the feeling pretty much.
Amongst those.
You don't have to leave in California.
And they're hungry.
He didn't really want to.
And I have to remember.
But I was really.
Right.
And I guess nobody wanted to be the first with him.
Yeah.
Because there was not that good feeling about.
You know.
You get quite a fair.
Yeah.
And so we're probably going to came down.
He ever told you that.
Hey, I'm going to be the coach next.
Because I know I'm being lying.
He was actually the coach when he came down.
Yeah.
You know, when he got in the job.
You already got in the job.
Oh, I see.
Right.
So yeah.
And I had read about it in the paper.
But I didn't think much of it really.
He called me.
And then he came to talk to me.
Right.
Okay.
So let's not carry the story on.
Just talk about you now.
Arriving on campus.
And what were some of your earliest recollections for you.
You're seeing the place.
What was that like?
One thing that was really funny.
There's a female named Charlie White.
Name Charlie White.
Yes.
Okay.
All right.
And they put her in one of the men's dorms.
The other men's dorms.
And I got to meet her later.
I got out.
I met her at a party.
Really.
Okay.
Yes.
So.
But anyway.
When I first got here.
They had us doing jobs in Cottage Grove.
Okay.
Logging.
So in the office.
Yeah.
But I came at the beginning of summer.
So went right into to work.
Okay.
Now Cottage Grove is down towards Eugene.
I think it's East to Eugene out in the wilderness.
Okay.
So they took me down there.
And I mean, this was not a good situation.
The first day I was there.
Yeah.
Took me in the evening.
And I said, right?
Me in the night.
Yeah.
So the next morning I get up and I come down and everybody's staring.
And then the next day someone told me that it would be good if I didn't come out at night.
Okay.
So I called Paul and said,
I'm leaving.
Yeah.
Now.
So they sent somebody and got me.
And I moved into Eugene.
There was some guys in Eugene that those fought for them.
Three of four guys in the department.
And it was, it was makes a couple of like students and a couple of, and they were
after these.
And they brought me down there.
And every morning when we would do, we would catch a bus from Eugene to the cat
as drove and work and then we come back to Eugene.
So, you know.
So they took the job.
Yeah.
But I didn't live in college.
Grow.
Yeah.
Because I told them I wasn't staying.
They need to get me out of here now.
Okay.
So I came to Eugene and then I worked at somewhere in the woods which was good.
We made a lot of money.
I was going to pay in a whole lot.
But at that time, it was a lot of money.
And we did actually play suspended.
So all of a sudden, along we worked, stuck checking the bank so the school started
and a little money.
Right.
That was common for us.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
We could work.
Okay.
Yeah.
Monthly stipend.
So then started a season.
And I could say, we had a, you didn't have a very good team.
We were seven, seven in the back.
But actually, it wasn't that bad.
Eight.
Everybody says the packing.
It was the A-A-W-U.
Which is the athletic association of Western universities.
Okay.
But it was the original eight schools, the two in Oregon, a two in Washington, two in
Southern California, two in Northern California.
It was the A-A-W-U.
The pack A-W-U.
The name pack A-W-U.
It came on later.
But anyway, we were seven, seven in confidence.
I think it was 14, 10 overall or something like that.
You know, we, you know, we weren't really thinking of anything big.
The next year, we just wanted to be competitive.
And I had played a small forward in the first year here.
But then they put me in guard the next year.
And, you know, and all the guys, the only new guy that came in really was that really helped us
was Harry.
The only new guy.
Harry Gunna.
Okay.
Yeah.
He's the only new guy.
African-American who came in.
Oh, and a lot of Peter's.
Yeah, I'll take that back.
A lot of them.
Okay.
So they came in and, you know, we, we'd be people like a good, seven, eight in deep, you know.
What year was that when they came in?
We didn't find it.
It was 65.
But boy, it was not African-American.
We married Harry Gunna was.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll tell you that part of the research time.
Yeah.
So tell me about though that that reception that you received,
you feel that you received from the student body in that first year and then in the next year.
That you feel.
Well.
Like I said, you know, I'm oblivious to a lot and I've been a lot of places and, you know, and
there.
Yeah.
And so I mean, sure, you got some looks.
And, you know, you know, you know, I just kept going, you know.
I was here to do what I was here to do.
One incident was a one of the freshman players who, I knew, you know, not very well,
but you know, I knew who he was.
We were on campus and he was with his girlfriend.
And he stopped.
And he introduced me and she made a comment, oh, you're the one in my girlfriend's class.
Yes.
Okay.
And I said the one what?
I don't know.
Yeah.
And she was totally embarrassed and couldn't even answer.
So I just said, I'll see you guys later.
Right.
But, you know, I was going to find you.
You know.
Yeah.
But like I said, most of the kids up here hadn't ever been around in any black people.
You've got a long go school with them or show them.
Yeah.
Because I had run into that.
And he owned me.
I mean, I mean, he lived mostly celebrities.
Yes.
He was seen.
They told me they'd seen back from a distance.
But, you know, they didn't know, you know.
Wow.
And that was that.
Yeah.
They're from the South, living in a little small town.
It should be in place like that.
Right.
But I didn't, I didn't feel anything in classes.
Yeah.
I don't feel anything.
Teachers or students in the classes.
Yeah.
Whatever's an occasional, yeah.
A lot of somebody's car, you know.
Okay.
Yeah.
And finding a combination in covalence and recreation in covalence.
What was that like?
Well, the one.
The main thing is when I was almost into when I came down.
It was already active.
But I have to get America.
So I don't have a problem with that.
And how did you find that?
Did the coach find that?
I think so.
Okay.
Yeah.
I think so.
But they were football players.
And one was a man athlete.
Okay.
Well, they're laughing at Jesus.
Pharmacist.
Okay.
Don't believe in a group.
We always turn it right.
He played tennis.
And he loved five.
Four or five.
Five.
And he was a lower weight, you know.
But he's one of my best friends.
He's in Canada.
He didn't even get me in California now.
But yeah.
They were there.
And then we moved to another house.
I think it was 17th near the Coliseum.
Okay.
And we never had a problem.
We went over there.
And the 80.
You know.
And the rent was 70 bucks a month.
Wow.
Then there was four.
It was sort of 1750 a month.
That's not bad.
You know, plus the oil.
And then the oil.
The furnace in there.
But yeah.
I was nice.
I never had any problem.
Finding a place.
He and those are only two places.
I lived in an apartment down in Canada.
I remember the street.
Okay.
But that.
Yeah.
I never had any problems with that.
Now in terms of, you mentioned going to parties.
Because then where you said you'd met up.
Chubby Brown.
I'm sorry.
Chubby White.
It's the female other party.
Did you go to parties that were integrated?
Or did you go to?
And when you had a social life.
What was that?
Well, all of.
Well, all the time I was here.
Not one white person I've been guided me to a party.
That I would go back and recall.
Okay.
Now I got invited to people's homes to have a dream.
So dinner.
You know, I was saying that.
But not ever once.
Team mates or anyone.
Never invited me to a party.
But we gave a party every weekend.
Okay.
You're blessed.
Yes.
A nice street.
A goal goal is what we called it.
That was a time to go go.
Yeah.
So all the.
Obviously all of the women at our parties were.
Wait.
Okay.
Well, with the exception of two to three.
Because there were.
Carol Smith.
And.
There was three of four.
African-American women kind of one.
I'm lived here in Corvales.
Okay.
There's a couple of ones from LA.
And another from.
I forget.
Second man over somewhere.
Okay.
But.
But the majority of women were.
White women.
Like women.
And also.
Well, like Peterson, who's white.
He came to one of two of my parties early on.
And everybody knew him.
And nobody, you know, even have any.
You know, he's from Los Angeles.
So he's been around black.
I can't afford playing ball with the black.
So he named.
I'm with that.
And this.
Charlie White.
See.
I guess he thought we were having a party.
She came to one of our parties.
And it should do this.
I thought she was kid in the.
But.
You know, we talked a lot of time.
I forgot.
She was from somewhere.
But.
Okay.
Yeah.
And that was pretty much.
Our parties were.
And like, see, we gave parties.
Every weekend.
And we would even.
Host.
Is the.
Other African.
And athletes.
When they came to talk.
If they were staying overnight.
You say, if you haven't a party.
We heard you guys come over.
Yeah.
And they would.
I mean.
And then we.
You know, I got.
We became friendly with all the athletes.
And in our.
In the conference.
Up and down the coast.
Because when they came up here.
Yeah.
You know.
We went to Washington.
Yeah.
You know, they host us.
You know, blah, blah, blah.
And then.
And I had a.
We had a friend who.
From Seattle who.
But school there.
So when we go up there.
You know, she would always have us.
You know, over to her place.
So.
And we go to Portland every now and then.
Yeah.
What was the relationship like with the police when you guys had these parties?
Was there any kind of?
I don't know.
But I don't know.
Police ever come into our house.
Okay.
Yeah.
I really don't.
I.
Yeah.
I don't.
Don't remember.
And what about fraternities?
I mean, that's always been a sore.
Point for a lot of students dealing with fraternities.
I think I got some.
I got a few from a couple of fraternities who they were.
I don't recall.
But I.
Wasn't anything I wanted to do.
Yeah.
It don't any campus.
Sure.
I've been in the military.
I knew how living in barracks.
And all that stuff with guys.
I didn't.
I had my field of that.
I didn't want to do anymore.
That.
I was just sitting on.
Yeah.
I wasn't getting.
I thought it was more of the attention that it occurs.
Because fraternity boys.
Yeah.
I always think to be down on.
You know.
But then.
No.
I think.
Yeah.
It wasn't interesting.
Okay.
Keep not talked to us a little bit about your going through school.
And so he said your process.
They went well.
What did you end up as a major in how did you sort of go on from there?
Well, I.
Major in business administration.
But the.
Concentration in personnel and industrial relations.
I came here and I started here in September of the 64.
And I graduated in December of 67.
And.
So I left here in 68.
67.
Okay.
I got a job.
With the company called Crown seller back.
Which was a large one of the largest paper manufacturing firms in the West Coast.
Okay.
And I got that through.
One of the alumni.
A guy who had played here with Paul.
Okay.
And he worked for Crown seller back.
Now.
At that time.
Affirmative action was big.
Really big.
Yeah.
Any.
Any black college graduate could.
Could find a job.
You know, and you know.
Whether you're qualified and not, and I said to say some.
But anyway, right.
I got a job with Crown seller back.
And my specific job was to integrate the workforce.
At this company.
Yeah.
And this was in any out California.
Okay.
Which was about as a racist as you could get.
Any act is right next to Pittsburgh, California.
Okay.
Now those two places are.
All nine.
Nine point nine.
I'm assuming we have African Americans in an area in the Pittsburgh.
And all the vice-living.
I can do that.
Okay.
Well, now went down there to look for a place to stay out.
Back on the door.
People would open the door.
It's laughing at my face.
Or some would open the door.
Right.
So I went in the Pittsburgh.
And I found this apartment.
I was over there.
It was just not very.
Not very.
Not a very nice place.
But anyway, I got hard to do that.
And then I did a pretty good job.
It was really interesting when I, you know, they wanted.
African Americans.
And they wanted more women.
Okay.
Now this is a manufacturing facility.
Yes.
Well, they had women working already.
Yeah.
But of course, the women could only do certain jobs.
Yes.
Right.
We're working in the, in the, in the factory was packing.
Okay.
You know, they couldn't, you know, the, no, they couldn't work in shipping.
Got it.
And they had one female left drug driver.
Maybe two.
They couldn't operate the machines.
Which paid the most money.
Yeah.
They couldn't do those jobs.
So they were pretty much dead.
You know, packing the boxes and that sort of thing.
Yeah.
That's where it was at that time.
It's also.
So, you know, I would hire people.
I would go out in the neighborhood.
I would go out in Pittsburgh where African Americans were.
Hispanics.
They didn't have a lot of Spanish.
We're going to either.
So I'd go out.
And I'd get 10 or 12 people to come in.
And at that time, they used to do all this.
Different testing.
One to late.
All that time.
Minnesota money.
Exactly.
PM MPI.
That took forever.
Yeah.
You know.
So anyway, we got ready at a some point.
But I have 12 15 people in the room taking this test.
Yeah.
You know, I'm helping them with it.
Because I'm trying to get people in there.
And then I started doing that.
And I'll tell you.
The people who had that facility.
They hated everything.
Yeah.
Now they were probably 10 or 12 black people working there.
And they had been working there for quite some time.
I mean, it weren't for a new people.
Yeah.
I don't think they'd have a black person probably in the last 10 years or so.
But I started filling them up with African Americans, Hispanics, and female.
Yeah.
And though they hated, they hated.
Do all this type of people that they hated.
I've been people out to the department.
Yeah.
To the supervisor.
And the workers were just stared me.
Yeah.
I got some bad meal in my inbox.
You know, about affirmative action.
And one guy was going to put a George Wallace on the sticker on my car.
And somebody stopped him.
You know what I mean?
It was bad.
Yeah.
I want to come back though.
Because I forgot what for you.
What are your stories?
You actually got elected as, you know, you got a word here.
No, it's called the Leadership Award.
What you got.
You know, I think it was 65, 66.
Yeah.
How did that feel?
That felt great.
Yeah.
Tell me about what happened.
What happened?
Well, it probably made me the captain.
Okay.
What was that like?
I didn't, you know, I'd surprised to me.
Okay.
And I didn't feel any angst from the team.
Mm-hmm.
I wasn't a yeller in a screamer anyway.
Not like, well, I was just a pro with a yeller.
Yeah.
But I would tell guys, you know, and we would have dialogue.
I wouldn't, you know.
You would give me this day.
You did that.
You know, we would, I'm going to do this.
Why don't you do that?
And when they come down here, let's make sure that we do this.
Sure.
You know, that was it.
Yeah.
That was it.
You know, it wasn't like this.
Yeah.
It was just like that.
We need to stop these guys.
And this is what we need to do.
Sure.
We're going to follow you, always.
Say, excuse me, in a huddle.
He'd say, this, this and this.
And then, as we broke the huddle, he would always say,
what you got to play the situation.
Because it may not come that way.
So you got to be a winning for it.
And that's what I say too.
Yeah.
They may not go that way.
They may come this way.
They've become this way.
We'll do this.
You know.
So yeah, and I feel good about that.
Yeah, I really did.
Yeah.
And he, he felt good about it too.
Paul and I had a real special relationship.
Yeah.
That's making the captain.
But more interesting.
You've reflected on the student leadership award.
Yeah.
Was there a leadership?
I think it was just with the team.
Yeah.
I think that was one of the things.
OK.
Sure.
Let's come back then to your, at the company in Anya.
Thank you, Tom.
So, was that your job you continued on with?
Or you said that you were.
Well, I did that for a while.
And then, I wanted to learn some more about the business.
So I took a production job.
OK.
And, well, let me go back.
Yeah.
When I was bringing these people into, uh, to go to work, they had what they called
The Probation Appearance.
For the new employees.
Which were only 30 days.
Which is not a lot of time.
No.
But they were terminating these people as fast as the most as fast as I could after two, two, three weeks.
Yeah.
Almost 30 days.
But they just say, where they can't do the job.
Yeah.
Right.
Now, I said, what do we do?
Something's wrong.
So, Hispanic, gentlemen.
And Leo, mehattis.
I don't remember.
He and I used to talk.
He came to me and said, you know, they don't, they're not giving these guys a chance.
Yeah.
They're not training them right.
So, after 30 days, these people can't do the job.
They're kicking them out.
Right.
So, we got to do something.
I said, well, he was a union, uh, stewed also.
So, I said, let's take what we're going to do.
We said, I only made up a form that had to be filled out every week.
But we supervised, we had to supervise it.
Right.
What was taught to this just, you know, right.
And this person, male female, whatever, had to agree.
So, at the end of the week, we were set out on with the union steward.
Yeah.
Myself.
Right.
And the partner supervise.
And not the guy who trained him with department supervisor.
He was going to go over that.
And they got said, nobody told me this.
Nobody told me that.
Didn't we could extend this probation if he had it.
And then we made sure that they got to correct training.
Right.
Because we did that on a weekly basis.
Took all the time.
But, you know, we did it.
Right.
And we kept started me and able to retain, uh, people.
Because, you know, hiring people.
Because my name's a lot of work.
And you send them for physicals.
You spend money and then they kick them out.
Right.
So, right.
So, we did that.
But then I wanted to, uh, expand.
So, I went out in production.
Worked production.
For a while.
Shiftwork, press production pay a little bit of money.
And then I was learning a little more about the business.
And then, um, the safety manager left.
And I decided, you know, I had enough of shift work.
And I decided to go back in the personnel office.
Since I've got my base scale up.
And I went back in as the safety manager.
Now, I worked there for eight years.
Okay.
And, um, you know, doing all this time.
And, uh, I didn't have an opportunity to go with a large construction firm called Long Star Industries,
which was, uh, covered, uh, five states, uh, California, Washington, Oregon, Utah, and Hawaii.
Oh, no.
Okay.
So, we still have to get up.
Yeah.
And I was regional safety manager, which was a big job.
You know, you get your car and stuff.
You get to travel a lot.
So, I took that job.
Yeah.
Did you have a family at that point?
Or you were still?
Yeah, I had one son.
Yeah.
I had a son in 1987.
Okay.
Sure.
Um, did you ever have any aspirations being a coach?
Because, I mean, after you leave basketball.
I mean, a lot of guys kind of me have that aspirations.
Hey, you know what?
I can probably do some of this stuff.
Well, you know, I, I did, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I've got a close
freshman here a little bit.
Okay.
You know, and I, right after I stopped playing.
And I, I guess the reason I didn't stay in coaching.
I wanted to get back to California.
Really.
And so I thought the quickest way for me to get back was to this pursue my degree.
But otherwise, I, I thought about it after.
It's not right after.
Maybe 10 years after.
But I was very disappointed when Paul quit.
97.
Yeah.
He only had to head coaching down for six, seven years.
He just gave it up.
I don't know.
Did you ever talk to him about why that was?
Because we didn't.
Well, yeah.
I don't know that he'd blown up.
Okay.
Well, that's okay.
All right.
You know, um, now in terms of your connection back to Detroit,
it sounds like that got severed a long time ago.
You know, that you never really would have aspiration to go back there.
No, not to live, no.
You kept calling me back there.
Oh, yeah.
It was like, yeah.
But what happened is, uh, six, five or six of my nieces and nephews came to California.
Oh.
But only one state.
Okay.
They all came.
One went to Los Angeles.
They stayed up wild.
I don't know.
They have a one state.
He's still in California.
But they all got someone back to Detroit.
But, you know, yeah.
My family other than my nephew.
Here's the, they're all in Detroit.
Okay.
And so you make regular.
Yeah.
I do.
I went back last year, twice.
So this year, just recently when I was in Las Vegas, my nephew graduated.
So a bunch of them came out.
So we had a nice little family.
Yeah.
And that's the weekend.
So I'm going back and I'll get stuff.
One of my nieces is really married.
So I'm going to go back for that.
But I'm going to be out of here before winter.
I do your thing.
Yeah.
I went back last September and stayed two weeks.
Okay.
Right.
Carry on the story a little bit further than you finished working eight years.
Or so he said, uh, as in any of the things that you want to do.
It's a supervisor position where you work.
Yeah.
First now.
Regional.
It's what else did you do outside?
Well, I worked that for a while and then that company got bought up and they
downsized and everything.
So I went to work for a shopping mall.
I was the safety director in a large shopping mall.
I've been near San Francisco.
And I worked there for quite a few years.
And then I got into contract security.
Okay.
We're going to contract security for him in Oakland.
I was at that.
I mean the branch manager there for.
I need to for 12 years.
Okay.
And then just before I was thinking about retiring, I went to work for Bayer.
Yes.
And I worked for them in Berkeley for two years.
And then I finally retired.
Two thousand four.
Okay.
But then I got bored.
So two thousand six rows around.
I met home and I look across the street and I see these kids playing basketball over there.
It was a school for.
Minuity challenge youth.
So I went over there.
Yeah.
I'm playing basketball.
I see what they were doing.
The people were there with nice.
They talked me in the driving the school bus.
Okay.
Yeah.
Because he's got a pretty hard.
They have a lot of female drivers in these guys.
They were tough on the limits.
So I do it after three and a half years.
And I enjoy it.
It's so nice.
And then I try not to escape.
Yeah.
No.
Coming back to playing volleyball or not just playing ball.
But after you left the audience,
they did your ever sort of just play or keep working out.
Or any of those kind of things with ball.
Yeah.
I played it.
And then I'm not there.
You but I played for different teams all over the Northern California.
Yeah.
We had a quite a quite a network of teams.
Sacramento.
You just have to march a dime.
Lake Tahoe had a tournament.
That a tournament down below Monterey.
And a little small town called Gonzalez, which was a bird.
But it was a real popular tournament.
It's a college place.
You see them all the time.
They go down there.
But you know, somebody would call me in the middle of the week and say,
we've got a game up in the Sacramento.
And I've jumping my car off the work.
And we're just a second middle.
I don't have a way.
And I'd go play.
Yeah.
I played a whole lot.
I don't remember when I stopped playing organized, but I played a lot.
Yeah.
What's the card not to play?
I went out of, you know, France for one of the first things I did.
It was fine.
I'm wearing a gas plate ball in the afternoon and I went over there and I went to work
down and there.
He even got out of college.
He put in the company team down.
Down in Cardine.
And he had those large companies around the duppin doll.
They're a USDA.
You know, stuff like that.
They all had teams.
And we, they've had a good league.
And we played the middle league.
And it was good.
We had a lot of fun doing that.
And now that you're in Annie, I can, those teams were mostly integrated.
And we never had any incidences that play involved, but you know, trying to do something
in town initially, they took a lot before they loosened up, and I got to meet several
policemen down there, and I used to hang out at the cop bar, so like everything was cool,
because someone had hired some of the policemen's kids.
Oh, and to the, okay, that's where we're working for the summers, you know, every year.
Oh, yeah, that was a good job.
No, yeah, they worked in, and so, you know, it was, it was pretty good.
Right.
Now, looking back on leavey organizations, did you ever, any aspirations are going on to play preferable?
Well, I did, I wanted to play, but I didn't get drafted, and I didn't want to go take a chance
and not make it, and then I'm not having to finish school yet.
Okay.
Now, they had the teams that they have now, all over the world, and Europe, and where else
you want to go to team, they have teams everywhere.
Yeah, sure, sure.
I probably could have gotten a drop of jobs away, because my nephew went down and played
in Argentina for 13 years, so yeah.
So, I could have, but that wasn't available to us at the time I came out, and I probably
would have jumped at that.
Right.
If I knew that I could go, you know, play for a couple of years in Europe, or someplace
in make a little money, and you know, because I could come back and finish.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, but you really put school to part of, which is a great thing.
Yeah.
Yep.
You thought, is there any other questions you want to ask?
At this point, because I think we're sort of at the end of what I had to ask.
They didn't even think of me, our cut perspective, they didn't want to ask.
Well, you mentioned Harry Gunner, so when he came on the team, it was the 65, 66 season,
and he was, did that change the dynamic at all?
Was that nice to have another?
Oh yeah, it was nice to have a plus.
He helped us a lot.
He needed his, you know, size and strength, you know.
He didn't start, but he played a lot.
Yeah.
He, he was our sixth man, and he was in first guy out to bed, usually.
And, yeah, it's done.
Right.
And now it's really funny.
Harry and I didn't always room together.
So, you know, because sometimes I'm annoying.
I used to room together most of the time.
But you could always find the three of us in one of our bedrooms,
the Harry's, you know, because we weren't being close.
Yeah, Roy used to hang with us.
Right.
Because Roy didn't, Roy hated this place.
He, oh, he hated every bit of life.
Right.
Coming from Los Angeles.
And he, he was one of those players that played, he was a playground player.
Sure.
Because he'd been playing with back kids all this time.
Right.
And he was a playground player.
He had more moves.
I'm tempted to count the words.
I'd say.
And he could play.
Right.
But he and Paul, man.
They just didn't.
He never got together for his three years here.
Wow.
Interesting.
And now he went on a play professional.
Oh, he did.
They created Chicago.
They've over several years.
Yeah.
And he found it.
Now, he married a girl from Madras, Oregon.
Oh, I didn't know.
Okay.
But he, he hated Oregon.
He, everybody came up here now.
And he, he had Paul just never.
Yeah.
They never got along.
Never.
Yeah.
I mean, they were a clarity to them.
In practice and on the bench.
Yeah.
And it was a hell of a player.
Right.
Yeah.
Now, in the movie glory road, there was actually, eventually, some tension
that occurred between the players.
Just about black and white, as you know, black players get in.
They saw the black players taking their shots.
Sure.
Like that.
No.
We just so few of you, anyway.
Yeah.
Well, first of just, please.
No, I never did.
I never got any feeling.
I've never felt that anywhere.
And I, and I, and I know I didn't definitely ever say that to me.
Right.
Yeah.
Have you also?
Well, I want to thank you very, very much.
Okay.
Great interview.
And it's been exactly almost 45 minutes.
Great stuff.
So we really appreciate it.
Okay.
I got to pick up parties.
I know he's probably championing it to be.
Okay.
Well, I'm pretty sorry about that.
Yeah.
Okay.
But thanks.
Are you going to be simple?
Yeah.
Can I give you his plaque?
Sure.
You're going to go.